[Music]
vanessa hudgins returns to her old
stomping grounds yup she's back on the
high school musical set nearly 16 years
later
[Music]
the actress posted a cute video taking a
trip down memory lane there she is back
at east high school where the cast
filmed the iconic disney channel
original movie it does feel like
lifetimes ago genuinely vanessa is
giving us major nostalgia rocking a
black tank top and hot pink shorts her
song of choice breaking free a fan
favorite from troy and gabriella
[Music]
vanessa's caption is also taking us back
a memorable quote from the original film
do you remember in kindergarten how
you'd meet a kid and know nothing about
them then 10 seconds later you were
playing like your best friends because
you didn't have to be anything but
yourself earlier this month e.t spoke
with vanessa before she hosted the mtv
movie and tv awards and she knows fans
are keeping the film alive through
social media the fact is kids are still
watching it kids are still being
introduced to it and like i just heard
gotta go my own way is trending on tick
tock
it never dies thanks to you guys
here's to the future
no
mr right now
[Music]
but fans really want to know could we
someday see the og cast back together
for ashley tisdale it's probably not
going to happen if it means slipping
into her role as sharpay
is there a part of you that ever thinks
about revisiting that character maybe re
visiting her with a more adult approach
or doing something with that in terms of
anyone
no i honestly i don't know i just feel
like i wouldn't be able to
to really do that again
and give it justice for me i would hate
to ruin
something that is perfect for that
moment and
um
yeah i don't i don't think i i don't
think i could could go back to it when
it comes to corbin blue and monique
coleman who play on-screen couple chad
and taylor they share a similar tune do
you
think that
there is a way
for
um
us to maybe ever ever revisit our
characters but in a in a more winky
sense i mean i i can't i i don't know
you know obviously there's the the
reboot of high school musical on
television and so forth
and i love taylor and i feel like i
learned a lot from taylor uh i can't
imagine what that story would be like
but i i can't say that i can't say that
it's not possible you never know what
about you i i feel exactly the same way
[Music]
you